oh no you didn't
no no no no that's that is not fair
that's not fair because what you said
the option was a dog sits on a head
no what happened there was a dog
teabagged
that was remarkable
[Music]
hello i'm jimmy carr and this is what
happens next for lad bible
spoiler alert what happens next is i
watch some clips
and then try and guess what happens next
i mean i watch a lot of stuff online and
normally someone has sex with someone
so that so the ball bounces off the
trampoline
and into the hoop well that would that
would be cool but not funny
the ball hits one of the kids in the
background
yes and the third option the ball hits a
bird
that flies bonnie at the wrong moment
well
i would go with a b i'd go because you
know i'm a believer
i think genuinely someone could be hurt
what's exciting okay he's thrown it
oh
[Music]
yeah genuinely funny okay so the options
are
a flock of seagulls descends on the
woman's garden
the a huge rat runs onto her mat
or her massive dog plunks itself down
on her head i'm gonna go with b i'm
gonna go with a rat
runs onto a mat because i think if a dog
sat on you i mean on the internet cute
dog stuff ten a penny why would you
waste my time with that
let's see if i'm right so b i'm going
with b a very clear b
oh no you didn't no no no no that's that
is not fair
that's not fair because what you said
the option was a dog sits on a head
no what happened there was a dog
teabagged
that was remarkable look at the size of
his balls on her chin
and you can see that she's just reaching
around to cup the other one
wow well i got it wrong but i'm very
happy i did because
that was better than i could have
imagined what am i looking at i'm
looking at a fox
and a cup of tea someone's left out a
cup of tea for a fox
okay so here comes here comes mr fox
i'm guessing he drinks the tea i mean
okay what are my options hey
the fox jumps into the man's car and
sits beside him
no the fox cheekily knocks over his cup
with his paw
and see the fox pees in the cup
i'm going to go with knocked over the
team with these poor i'm not i'm gonna
say not cheekily i'm gonna say like
here he comes
get away from me bro hey
oh legends
so last clip let's see what happens next
so there's children
playing football one of you is tackling
each other hopefully some sort of
aircraft
kicking off so look here they are
oh no all right soccer well let's see
what the options are
the goalkeeper sprints back on and
scores from his own net
now i could see that happening b the dad
pushes over the goalkeeper
okay dad pushes over goalkeeper this is
sounding spicy
see the net falls down before the ball
can roll in
yeah let's go with that
[Music]
[Laughter]
i mean that was an excellent save it's
not a hand ball as it's like a hand
player
[Music]
and because if you got more wrong and
you got right you're afraid to lost this
time
i mean that's that's that's a lot of fun
i wish that was my full-time job
oh you're little beauty it is that's a
big cow as well that's not even
that's not a large cow that's a an
extremely large cow
how has that happened the other guy's
working at spa who only ever lets like
two school kids in at once
how what's the rule for cows just one
cow at a time
at spa